[Music]
you are heading in there solo
how do you feel about it how did you
feel when you got the call
oh my gosh getting the call is the most
surreal feeling ever because like i
always say big brother is a once in a
lifetime opportunity
so to hear that you're getting it a
second time is
very hard to process it's very exciting
it's very scary knowing it's all stars
you know i i've watched the show for
over a decade
so you know it's kind of like oh gosh
who's gonna be in there with me
well if you are an all-star how does it
feel
dubbed that oh my gosh um i find it
extremely humbling to be called an
all-star like i don't
consider myself really like you know i
just consider myself nicole from long
island
um i can't believe i even got the chance
to go on last season
so to be considered to come back and to
be considered an all-star that just
blows my mind and i appreciate it so
much and i love it's amazing
well as somebody who's a huge fan of the
show you know these players who are you
excited to possibly see
in there and who are you nervous to
possibly see in there
oh gosh i would say when it comes to who
i'm excited to see
i would say my bb 21 fam um
i'm very family oriented i'm very loyal
so if i see anybody from my chaos last
season like those are the people i'm
looking for because i feel like there's
like that
bond that already exists i think it's
kind of an unspoken
alliance and understanding um i'm very
scared
to see people that i'm huge fans of that
i know
are manipulators and puppeteers and
beasts
so i'm scared to possibly see like you
know
the dance and the derricks and the
janelles in the polls only because
i know how much i love to see them take
everybody else out
and now that i'm playing it i don't want
them to take me out so it's like
i know could that be a bit of a conflict
if you're kind of
fangirling but also know you've got to
compete absolutely i think it'll be a
conflict like
for the first couple minutes when you
meet everybody and your star struck
and you think of yourself you know as
nicole the fans sitting on my couch
oh my gosh i mean these people but you
quickly go into game mode when there's a
competition so i think that's going to
wear off very quickly
it has to it has to yes so
you're going in there it's been so long
since the last all-star season why this
is the right time
oh my gosh first of all um an all-star
season is long overdue
um it's been wow over a decade so many
amazing players that
could potentially be in that house but
also like right now with kobit
everybody's at home there's not a lot of
shows filming there's not a lot of new
shows airing
and i think a lot of people are looking
for a community and camaraderie and
people to
connect with and i think me as a fan
like when i watch big brother like
those are my people those are my family
they're my friends i want to see them
play
so i think a lot of people at home
they're going to get that
personal connection that they've been
lacking for so many months like oh i get
to watch
my family compete because bb is such
like a community and i
look forward to like seeing all those
dynamics how do you think
having been quarantined will affect
the players the house guests heads going
into this
we've been through quarantine and global
pandemic
unprecedented times a movement
of the crazy political climate where
will everybody's heads be at and what do
you think that will do the game
um i think if anything it kind of helped
everybody i think it puts everybody in
that mindset of
being quarantined and being locked away
and getting a little stir crazy so
there's like two sides of the coin you
have the people that that mentally
prepared them and they're ready to go
because they've already been in it
but you also have the people that are
already itching to get out of quarantine
and now they're going to get in that
house and be like i can't do this
anymore get me out
so i'm hoping i full on the ready side
and everybody else falls on the i can't
do this side
i agree with you i can see people either
being you know
they've been so s they're they're so
emotionally on edge or
there is this excitement maybe of look i
get to be in a space where i can hug
people and it just feels normal i am so
looking forward to being able to hug
like 15 people
so exciting i don't know if anybody's
maybe ever been so excited not just for
big brother
but to be around people yes yes um i
mean
could this be the most pda heavy season
the show's ever had
oh i don't know you know when i think of
all-stars i think of a lot of people
that you know are married and have kids
and have relationships and whatnot so i
don't think there'll be a lot of pga
unless i don't know unless there's a lot
of single people in the house in which
case
you guys do you i won't be partaking but
they're more than welcome to
no why not are showmances off the table
for you i don't know it's just not my
style
to be in a showmance it's not my style
to act on feelings in front of cameras
and microphones it's just not the way i
am um if other people do it all power to
you but that's just not
no okay okay
never say never i don't know
i mean unless my future husband's in
that house then i mean it is what it is
you just said a lot of people people
have met their spouses on big brother
sometimes when you're not looking that's
when stuff happens this is true this is
very true
um if you think about uh
anybody who you think you could really
potentially get along with or connect
with who could
be on all-stars with you who are those
people um
hands down obviously when i think of my
cast cliff eclipse in that house like
that's my guy
always and forever so i'd love to see
him um from other seasons
um i would say somebody that i've been
thinking a lot of like lately would be
like alyssa
um rachel's sister alyssa slater because
like you know we were both kind of like
on a controversial season
we were both like the underdog gal ended
up becoming afp
that's somebody who i think we're very
similar in our approach to the game and
our like moral compass
well you were afp but you did not get
that win
your whole body film
what do you have to prove this time
around oh my gosh
i have to prove so much not even to
everybody else but to myself i need to
prove that i can do it and i will do it
i want the confetti this time you know
last time i was like oh as long as i get
there i just want to be at finale
and then when i saw somebody else get
the confetti i was like
damn like i i like shiny things like i
want to walk out and have like the
cannons go off and people clap like
that's awesome
so i need to prove to myself more than
anything that i can do because i know i
can do it i will do it
all right she will do it yes you want to
win
i am going to win like you're looking at
the bb22 all-star winner like i hope you
know that
you are speaking that right into
existence yes i want to win
it's i'm going to win i am going to win
yes
if you have one word to describe the way
you're going to play this game
this time around what is it i would say
i am going
to play the game
more confidently more like i hate to use
this phrase but like balls the wall like
not being
afraid to talk to people not being
afraid to walk into a room where people
are already you know having a
conversation
not being afraid of feeling awkward
during a comp and just
going for it like i think it was a lot
of what held me back last year when i
saw people talking
i was like oh that's awkward i'm not
going to walk in or i'm not really
athletic i don't really know what to do
during this comp like this time like
go big or go home to give it all i got
every day all day
and you know you have been on
back-to-back seasons
i mean you will be do you think that
gives you
an advantage is it a hindrance at all
how do you see it
i see it as a huge advantage i see it as
i never left the game mindset like i was
in that game
99 like i didn't even leave early like
99 days straight i was in game mode
came home ended up in quarantine again
and now here i am back to game mode
the way i see it i never left so i think
i have the advantage
of i didn't have really life get in the
way like i'm still
[Music]
playing
you